[Music]
you have a very inventive mind you you
thought of anything recently that you
could sell as a product see I look at
things that happen to me then I go back
home and think of how can I remedy this
situation so here's my idea I love
s'mores
oh I love s'mores everyone I think
everyone loves small who doesn't like
s'mores
you don't have time to go camping all
the damn time
right right you want to walk down the
street New York maybe Chicago through
the city
if s'mores so here's my idea right a
s'more is a graham cracker marshmallow
and chocolate mm-hmm hit the problem the
fire that's the problem right yeah you
need a campfire of course in this
campfire so it's wrong do I get a belt
designed with a big old bowl in front of
me propane tanks on both side that's in
case it runs out of gas understand sure
Oh little compartment for my chocolate
little squeezy Milo's topic you know
reservoir maybe little sticks put the
marshmallows on a little fire right
then I make my s'more and I use the fire
that's in front of me to eat my s'mores
right wait and you'll make s'mores right
in front of me while I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go
you mean you say that you're walking
around the city you're walking around
Chicago and there's a fire does what's
laws are you make fire to make the
s'mores the Moss bottles must melt okay
so that's
have you ever pressed your junk up
against a Weber grill because that's
essentially what you'd be doing your rug
that's a good point yeah that's why I
also designed and I can buy you put it
in your butt
I've got a fire retardant suit a fire
retardant suits just underwear so you
know well does math or yeah why don't
make it much more right that's a good
idea
no no no no that's that's that goes up
you're crazy yeah how about a store that
sells loose stuff all loose nothing in
package it's all loose stuff what do you
mean loose stuff like like for example
why you need a store describe what
you're saying that sounds like a [ __ ]
many times how many times have you used
a band-aid right you bought a whole box
right right use one band-aid right then
it's at three or four years before you
cut this up again so you're winning it
you're saying a store where you go in
and you buy one band-aid loose stuff one
band-aid you need a band-aid fine Alice
missiles antsy so it's gonna be more
expensive than always more money the
less you buy the more money it is five
dollars for a band-aid tip you want a
super soldier sometimes you get snow
parched you don't want to buy a whole
soda you want a sip yeah wait you do
anyway just get a sip this is like the
Android Costco yeah the anti glass co
yeah yeah episode of you get a sip and
then you put it back I'll wipe it off
and I'll put
before losers Balkans
you